♪ ♪
>> Laura: IT’S TIME FOR OUR
SEEN AND UNSEEN SEGMENT WHERE WE
REVEAL THE
STORIES BEHIND THE HEADLINES.
FOR THAT, WE GO TO FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND ARROYO.
WE’VE BEEN REPORTING, BIDEN
UNVEILED HIS BIG CLIMATE
INITIATIVE TODAY.
>> IT WASN’T ONLY ABOUT CLIMATE
REGULATIONS, IT WAS ABOUT JOBS!
>> TODAY IS CLIMATE DAY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, WHICH MEANS THAT
TODAY IS A JOB STAY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WERE NOT GOING TO LOSE JOBS, WE
ARE GOING TO CREATE JOBS.
PREVAILING WAYS TO TAP THOSE
OVER 1 MILLION WELLS.
THESE AREN’T PIE-IN-THE-SKY
DREAMS, THESE ARE CONCRETE
ACTIONABLE SOLUTIONS.
WE KNOW HOW TO DO THIS.
THE OBAMA-BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
RESCUED THE AUTO INDUSTRY AND
HELPED THEM RETOOL.
>> HE WAS RIGHT THE FIRST TIME.
THE OBAMA BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
DID REDUCE THE AUTO INDUSTRY.
IF THEY SPENT $23 BILLION ON A
UNITED AUTO WORKERS BAILOUT.
THIS WAS A SWEETHEART TAXPAYER
FUNDED DEAL TO SHIELD THEIR
UNION FRIENDS FROM TAKING PAY
CUTS DURING THE AUTO
BANKRUPTCIES, PERIOD.
THE BIGGEST JOKE OF TODAY WAS
BANNING OF NEW GAS AND OIL
LEASES IS GOING TO CREATE MORE
JOBS.
HE SAYS, THEY CAN CLOSE THOSE
ABANDONED WELLS.
UNDER BIDEN’S PLAN, THERE WILL
BE MANY, MANY MORE ABANDONED
WELLS.
IT’S LIKE ME SAYING, MY POLICIES
ARE GOING TO CREATE TONS OF
GOING OUT OF BUSINESS SIGN
MAKERS.
THAT’S NOT GOOD.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND, BACK
IN THE RADIO DAYS TRACKING
BIDEN’S PROMISES ABOUT GREEN
JOBS, I THINK IT WAS 2009?
>> MORE GREEN JOBS MEANS MORE
MONEY IN YOUR POCKET AT THE END
OF THE MONTH.
>> THE MONEY LANDED IN SOMEONE
ELSE’S POCKET, LORI.
IT WASN’T THE TAXPAYERS.
OBAMA AND BIDEN PROMISED
5 MILLION GREEN JOBS AS PART OF
THAT $787 BILLION STIMULUS
PACKAGE.
THE ONLY THING GREEN WAS THE
PILES OF CASH SPENT ON THIS.
THEY NEVER HIT THEIR GOAL, AND
TO REMEMBER, THEY COUNTED
JANITORS, CLEANERS, AND TO BUS
DRIVERS JOBS.
THIS WAS A BOONDOGGLE FROM A
START TO FINISH.
>> Laura: WHEN THEY GO BACK
AND THEY KEEP SAYING, IT WILL
ALL BE SOLAR, SOLAR HAS SOME
GREAT JOBS.
I’M SURE THERE WILL BE SOME
JOBS, BUT WHAT’S GOING TO STOP
THE SOLAR PANEL MANUFACTURERS
WITHOUT TRUMP’S TARIFFS AND
OTHER TRADE PROTECTIONS IN PLACE
FOR MOVING OVER TO ASIA, WHETHER
IT’S CHINA OR VIETNAM OR INDIA,
THEY WILL ALL MOVE OVERSEAS.
WE WILL BE LEFT WITH NO OIL AND
GAS JOBS, AND NO SOLAR PALIN PAN
JOBS.
>> CHINA WILL
DOMINIC WHICH IS WHY IT WAS
ASTOUNDING THAT AFTER YEARS OF
RUTHLESSLY FACT-CHECKING
TRUMP, "THE WASHINGTON POST" HAS
ANNOUNCED THEY ARE BACKING OFF
OF BIDEN AND TO DISCONTINUING
THEIR LIE TRACKER.
WE HAVE NO PLANS TO START A
BIDEN FALSE OR MISLEADING CLAIMS
TRACKER, JUST AS WE HAD NO PLANS
AT THIS POINT TO START A TRUMP
TRACKER.
THE CONSTANT TWEETING OF
FALSEHOODS FORCED OUR HANDS, BUT
WE WILL HAVE AN OPEN MIND.
>> Laura: JIM ACOSTA AT CNN,
HE BELIEVES THE FACT-CHECKERS
SHOULD NOT BE PACKED AWAY JUST
YET.
>> WE NEED TO DEVOTE IN OUR NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS SOME RESOURCES TO
FACT-CHECKING THESE FRINGE IDEAS
THAT ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
EXIST ON THE FAR RIGHT IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AT THIS IS NOT A TIME TO PUT
AWAY OUR FACT-CHECKERS AND SOME
SORT OF BOX ON THE SHELF.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE NEEDED TO
FACT-CHECK THIS MOVEMENT WHICH
IS NOT GOING AWAY.
IT TRUMP MAY BE GOING AWAY,
BUT --
>> IT’S THE MOVEMENT, LAURA!
THE BAD MAN AT MAR-A-LAGO, HE
NEEDS TO BE FACT-CHECKED, NOT
THE GUY SPENDING BILLIONS OR
EXECUTIVE -- ISSUING EXECUTIVE
ORDERS LIKE THEY ARE CANDY AT
HALLOWEEN.
I’VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
IT.
IF YOU’RE NOT, LAURA.
THE "LOS ANGELES TIMES" IS
STEPPING INTO THE GAP.
THEY HAVE LAUNCHED A NEW PROJECT
CALLED, COVERING KAMALA HARRIS,
WHICH THEY SAY IS DEDICATED TO
HER HISTORIC RISE TO THE
WHITE HOUSE -- OR AT LEAST THE
NAVAL OBSERVATORY.
I GUESS THEY DON’T REALIZE THE
VICE PRESIDENT DOESN’T LIVE AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Laura: LET’S LOOK AT SOME
OF THE PENETRATING COVERAGE,
IT’S PRETTY TOUGH FROM THE
"LOS ANGELES TIMES."
THIS IS FROM THEIR INSTAGRAM
ACCOUNT.
OKAY.
IT’S JUST A REPOSTING OF HER OWN
SOCIAL MEDIA PROPAGANDA.
WITH ABSOLUTELY NO COMMENT.
>> SINCE WHEN IS HUGGING A
SPOUSE NEWS?
THERE ARE SOME IMPORTANT
REPORTS.
HERE’S ONE, HOW KAMALA HARRIS’
DECISION TO JOIN A SORTER HELPED
HER BECOME VICE PRESIDENT.
MY FAVORITE, MIGHT GRANDMOTHER
IS NAMED, LOW, AND NOW THE
VICE PRESIDENT’S.
THIS IS LIKE TEEN BEAT.
>> Laura: THIS IS A TIGER BEAT
OF POLITICS.
TRUMP’S GONE, TRUMP’S GONE,
TRUMP ISN’T.
DOES HE NOT UNDERSTAND THAT HE’S
JUST PROVING TO EVERYONE THAT
HE’S AN IDEOLOGUE ON THE LEFT
WHO HATES POPULIST
CONSERVATIVES.
OKAY, THEN BE ABUNDANT.
DON’T STAND THERE WITH THEIR TIE
ON AND BE SOME OBJECTIVE